now comfort during the pandemic it can  come in all forms  for one southern california doctor a  method of therapy was as simple as  air dr stephanie lowe started learning  balloon  art during the pandemic and now she's  using it to help her patients  but the colorful creations are really  impressing people not only staying at  the hospital but  those who work there their requests kind  of challenged me i'd be like oh you want  an elephant okay i'm gonna learn how to  do that i'd go home and learn how to do  it and bring it in  love to see that dr lowe says she's  happy to bring a little bit of joy  as we go through the darkness of the  pandemic